we're learning new details this morning
about the sexual harassment
investigation that led to the
resignation of new york governor andrew
cuomo the information is also raising
some fresh questions about the role of
the former governor's brother that's cnn
anchor chris cuomo in defending him our
national correspondent jerica duncan has
been following that story and joins us
in the studio with the latest good
morning to you good morning gail the new
york attorney general released almost
nine hours of video footage of andrew
cuomo's testimony in july where he
repeatedly and at times
compatibly denies claims of sexual
harassment six of his accusers video
testimony was also released they
detailed cuomo's alleged misconduct the
release also included new written
testimony and evidence about the
ex-governor's brother cnn anchor chris
cuomo transcripts show the younger cuomo
was more directly involved than
previously known about and how the
governor should respond to the
allegations and the crisis swirling
around him chris cuomo said this on his
cnn program in august after the
governor's resignation
i'm not an advisor i'm a brother i
wasn't in control of anything i was
there to listen and offer my take
and my advice to my brother but text
messages reveal he was often in contact
with his brother's top aide melissa
derosa and one he begs to help the
governors prep for his responses and
another he says he will use his sources
to find out about possible new accusers
coming forward an email from cbs news
regarding norah o'donnell's interview
with andrew cuomo's former assistant
executive was even forwarded to chris
cuomo for his thoughts on then the
upcoming story cnn has said it is now
looking into the new documents and will
seek additional clarity about their
significance as they relate to cnn over
the next several days an attorney for
chris cuomo told cbs news that was
honest with that he was honest with
investigators and andrew cuomo denies
any wrongdoing
in a statement his spokesperson said the
attorney general who is now a candidate
for governor here in new york state
released the edited video of testimony
to damage political opponents uh it's a
lot lot to be said here tony a lot going
on the the plot thickens and deepens
we'll keep following it thank you very
much